Pixar what happened brave as you
probably guess from my intro not a huge
fan of this movie it's not a complete
waste but actually that's what kind of
makes it really infuriating for me
because there are parts and components
that are excellent in this movie and
then they just get wasted I'm getting a
little bit ahead of myself though why
don't we start with what works
this was Pixar's first crack at a
princess story which is a Disney
standard and you know what the princess
herself Merida loved her I loved her
visually I loved it's crazy mane of hair
that she's got I love that she's into
archery I'm a sucker for archery I used
to do it when I was younger so she kinda
hooks me in a little bit there I love
her attitude they sort of play that
independent woman but it's not so much
that it over does and makes her feel
like a character who's like out of time
right think she still feels very much of
that time in of that era she's just
she's just stubborn as heck I like
really pretty much the whole first half
hour of this movie where everything's
getting established because I love the
setting the location and the way that
it's realized it's just gorgeous
I love Merida's dad I love Billy
Connolly the man is amazing and he's
terrific in this I think I'm on - it's a
pretty good balance being caring but
still trying to reel this wild girl in a
little bit the thing opens really well
it builds really well the initial setup
is strong and then the whole thing just
goes completely off the rails once the
main plot actually kicks in you know
maybe that's an overstatement to say
that it completely goes off the rails
it's not that it's something that
becomes a bad movie it just very
suddenly becomes a movie that's not
nearly as good as it started out to be
or as it should be because the actual
story that they choose to tell the the
hinge of the plot and what actually
becomes the main conflict and what has
to be done to resolve that is a waste it
is a waste of a fantastic character and
of a fantastic setting because they
really make good use early on of the
setting in terms of the the clans and
the sort of the tensions between them
and the will of the wisp is a great bit
of
regional folklore but then when the
actual main thing kicks in it has this
mystical element to it that is not in
any way tied into or unique to that
setting and there's a ton of mysticism
folklore all this stuff from that part
of the world and they don't use any of
it they have this mystical aspect that
really could have happened anywhere and
ultimately that's really what
disappoints me is they've got this
amazing character this amazing setting
and then the story they actually tell
didn't require either of those the story
could have been done with a lesser
character in any setting and the story
itself would it could have been told
just as well and again the story is not
terrible but this character this setting
deserves so much better I can actually
pinpoint where the thing goes off the
rails and that is the scene with the
witch just tone alone everything goes
completely out of whack when that scene
happens now it's a good scene don't get
me wrong but it feels like it's from a
completely different movie it feels like
it's from a Shrek movie and I don't mean
that derisive Lee it would be one of the
better scenes in a Shrek movie but it
just it's not in keeping with what's
going on up to that point now I'm kind
of dodging about what actually happens
following the witch scene because I'm
trying to keep this spoiler free I
understand most people who want to see
it I've seen it right now but I spoil
the fries kind of my mantra but have you
seen the movie you know what I'm talking
about and you know I I'll be honest
maybe part of the reason I'm so hard on
this movie is because it won the Oscar
and it didn't deserve it it didn't even
come close it won the Oscar over
ParaNorman which was a gorgeous mature
fun funny intelligent movie and over
wreckit-ralph which was one of the
biggest surprises for me of that year
that movie touch that movie still
touches me it makes me cry that movie is
powerful a million times more than brave
whatever be so the fact that brave one
it's just it's insulting it's like all
Pixar Pixar's the best no no not
automatically not always so maybe I get
a little more riled up against this
movie then as necessary just because of
how frustrated I am at the wasted
potential and the fact that it won an
Oscar the movie in an episode it's not
bad it's not
bad movie but it could have been so much
more and so much better and it should
have been it was made by people who
should know better
Iida what are you gonna do so have you
seen brave what were your thoughts on it
did you love it did you hate it most
people I know seem to find it somewhere
in the middle let's talk at the high end
though what do you think is Pixar's best
movie I could go a couple of directions
on that question myself I kind of lean
towards the Incredibles a little bit but
honestly there's a couple of others
right up there it's it's not an easy
call but whatever you think it is drop
something down in the comments and we'll
talk about it that's for me I'll be back
as soon as I can get my next fix